Hi, good morning. Good morning, everybody. Good morning to you. Good afternoon. Oh, what a wonderful day. Oh. Or a good evening for maybe some of our listeners. It could be an evening lesson. I'm just saying, depending on where you are, good, that time of day. I think most people listen to this show during the day or during the night. You know what? That's a really great question.
And we'll get to it right after this all-new episode of Smartus. God. smart bless smart bless I will say in the blind right now my wife said to say to the guest
that she loves them so I don't know who this is but just know half of my house loves you already oh that's nice yeah because Will talks to my wife more than I do and it's something we should get into. Hi, Willie. Let's go there now.
Let's go there now. Will, why do you talk to my wife so often? You talk to her as if, I don't want to say some of these crasses, there's something going on, but it's, let's put this way. I'm married to her and I live with her and I talk to her X amount.
You talk to her X plus amount. So where does that put your relationship with her? Well, let me just say this. Is there something going on? don't ask me point blank should I ask you kind of in a nuanced way I'm just saying don't ask me point blank
because you don't like to lie to me I don't like lying okay if you were to cheat on one of your friends wives would you would I be in the running or husbands
you be yeah you have been in the running sorry you would sorry this is hypothetical about Amanda or you are the running Well, I thank you, Mr. Mark. It's a compliment to you that I love your wife. No, I do love your wife so much. I love her.
She and I have a special, she and I have a special relationship as well. Are you talking to us from a gorgeous new place in New York? Not new. No, no, no. I'm just in that same place. Oh. The rental? Yes, sir.
But did you not just get another new kind of? Maybe, yeah. I maybe did. Maybe I did that. You might actually get them. I want to stay there. Can we stay there when we come visit? But not yet. You have a place here.
Oh, that's right. Yeah, that's right. It's uptown, though. I'm sorry. Should we take a break? Yeah, Sean, we'll just give you a minute. Are you still on lunch? We're not back yet?
Snickerdoodle. Fuck, man. It's not, it's just 11.30. I know. I know I have a late lunch, so. By the way. So I just had a chicken wrap and a snickerdoodle and glass of milk. Wait, wait, but you just said you have a late lunch coming up.
Yeah, coming up. Right. So why are you eating lunch food and tonight's dessert now? This is tying you over at 11.30. What times your lunch? 2 o'clock. Oh, my God. So you're going to eat dinner at 2.30?
Kind of like, it's like I'm going to be a weird thing because then who wants to eat at 5 or 6 when I normally eat? Are you powerlifting these days? Are you into powerlifting? What's happening? You got a big contest coming up? I would love if you just stood up and your legs, your glutes and everything were just popping.
You know, I think I recognized that snickerdoodle from the country mart. No. Because I had one this weekend. Oh, yeah, no, they're pretty big. I do like a snickerdoodle. They're really good. What's your current favorite cookie, Willie?
It's always, always, it's current and always chocolate chip cookie. Yeah, for sure. In search of the best chocolate chip cookie. It's my thing. You know, you know, I like a nice peanut. butter cookie because they're usually soft and gooey in the middle? They're often too
dry for me. You remember we were on the set of Is This Thing On Coming out or it's already out I think Oh, that's a movie. That's a movie there folks. And the craft service lady made Fresh Chocolate Chip Kicks. Remember those, Will? And Will's like, I know, I couldn't believe it. And you're like, boy, that smells
really good. Sounds like someone on the set was honoring the fact that it was an on-camera job, Sean. Not me. I ate like five of them. You still eat like you're doing a podcast? That's right. Eat like you're doing a podcast.
That's really good. Hey, kudos to us on the podcast. We got a nice of recognition today. We just found out today, yeah, gang. We got a little golden globe now. And I want, we did. And I want to say, I want to say a lot of it has to do with our friends, Michael Terry and Bennett Barber Cow and Rob Arm Yarb.
Those guys, these are the winds beneath our wings. Yeah, and that's why I'm happy. I'm happy for those dudes because of how hard they work and we love them so much. Thank you, guys. We love you. We don't need to hear from you. We love you. Who turns your mic on?
You know what Bennett and Rob and Michael would like? They would like probably for the three of us to show up to set awards show in the event we're lucky enough to win. They'd probably like us to get up there and give a nice speech and not be stuck in New York at a play or stuck in Long Island petting a dog or something like that. I would love to, but I'm not going to be, yeah, I can't. I love to, but Robin Bennett and Michael should go in our stead.
That's what I think. No, you're both coming. Wait till Amanda gets a hold of you both. I know, by the way, she already did. Yeah. Willie, maybe we fly back together just for the night. Yeah, there you go. Well, we'll talk about it.
All right. Oh, guys, the one thing I do want to mention before we go. I want to say that we want to let you know about a new smartless media show that is celebrating the world's dumbest criminals, right? You want to let the audience know. Sean and I are well aware. This is a great little child of smartless media. What's it called? What's it called?
What's called? Okay? It's called crimeless. It's hosted by journalist Josh Dean and comedian Rory Scoville. Yeah. What do they do? What do you mean?
Every week, Josh tells Rory a story or two or three, you know, about some ridiculous stranger than fiction crime starring some of the most hilarious ding-dongs that you guys could possibly imagine. I want you to think of like, you know, like Cohen Brothers films, but it's real.
Yeah, crimeless. It's like dumb-dums. It's like crime, dumb-dum-taking crime. It's talking like stage deaths and what, like pretend hitting in or fake drugs. Yeah, like insurance scams,
but done by idiots. Wow. People that don't know how to pull it off, you know. Okay, so we got new episodes of this and when are they coming out? People were like, I want to get it when does it? When would you want to hear it?
You'd want to hear it on a hump day, right? That's right. Just to get you through the week. To get you through the week. Wednesday, perfect on a hump day. Yeah, all right. And wherever you get your podcast, crimeless. Okay.
So, anyway. Hey, Will, you feeling good about your guest? I'm feeling really good. In fact, I want to say, speaking of which, our guest is a Golden Globe nominee, freshly minted. I think he has a couple. Yeah, that's right. Guys, we have somebody who is O'Carrant, as they say.
Oh. He's a very, he is an award-winning, celebrated actor. He says O'Carrant. I do. And my mom. You know him is A lot of people know it as Karmie From his acclaimed FX series
Okay He's earned him an Emmy A Golden Globe Sagward for Best Actor He was just nominated for Golden Globe For Deliver Me From Nowhere You guys, it is Mr. Jeremy Allen White All right You know I will second
My wife's love for you Now that I see you Everybody's love for you My deep love And not only that Jeremy Before you start welcome he's also, he was also my surprise guest for a rained out Hollywood Bowl.
I just found that out. I just found that out too. This is, this is, this is, this is not as good as loving up on you on the Hollywood Bowl stage, but we'll take it. We'll take it for sure. I'm so happy, I'm so happy to see you guys. I was just texting Amanda as you guys spoke about her. Oh, everybody's on with you guys.
Everybody's sleeping with Amanda. Let me, Jason, let me say, and I mean. Sean, if she turns you, that's going to be it. Jason, I mean this in the most friendly way. Friendly, friendly way, and I mean this in a nun, but your wife really gets around. To texting people. To texting people.
Yeah, yeah, to let you finish. Let me finish, God, is what I said to her. You know, listen. She's a lover. She's a real lover. She's a lover. We love it. Jeremy, welcome.
Jeremy Allen White, welcome this one of us. This is so nice. It's so nice to meet you. I'm really happy to meet you. Yeah, yeah. Congrats on the nomination. You guys have never met. Yeah, congrats on the nomination.
And Sean, you and Jerry Allen White have never met. Never met, but I'm a big fan. I'm a big fan. Oh, wait, do you meet him? You'll be in love. I'm serious. I thought the eating thing, also, I listen to the show a lot. I'm a subscriber, all of it.
I thought the eating thing was like a bit. It's all a bit. No, a lot of time. When you brought out that cookie, I couldn't believe it. Show them the milk, too. I bet you got milk right there. I got milk there. Unreal.
But Jeremy, here's one thing. First of all, Sean, enough with the Foley work. Do you need to keep it in the sleeve? You're already, like, are you trying to... You're at home. No, I'm keeping it fresh. I'm keeping it fresh.
What do you mean? In a paper bag? There's just a wax paper that's open on one end. How is that keeping it fresh from six minutes that you're taking to eat it? Can you grab a hat? What's going on with your hair? I know.
Sorry. It's like, you're going to catch on fire in a second. I'm going to buy you some product for Christmas. We're going to get Jan to send some LolaVee over. She should have an emergency crew. You know, I'll call her on Smartless Mobile to get me some LolaVee. Smart. Very smart.
Anyway, Jeremy, welcome. Yeah, where do we find you? I'm in Los Angeles. I just got back the other day. I was in Vancouver for a little while, and I'm in this house. Are you in an office in your house? Yeah, it's like, I try to make it an office, but it just becomes kind of storage. How do you feel about that AC unit that's sticking out of the wall?
I mean, they work, right? No, I'm wearing the hat right now. It's like my house is falling apart. Nothing really works here. I got that put in recently. It doesn't work, so it's pretty chilly in here. But this is like a separate kind of room, not a guest house. There's nothing in here.
The acoustics are good. Yeah, the acoustics are great. Can you give us a song? I think Robert Bennett are laughing right now. No, no. Hey, is that a chef's apron behind your left shoulder? Yeah, yeah, I've got, yeah, the chef's apron. It's like a collection of little stolen things.
Everybody needs a spot for them, you know. And Jeremy, you can tell us those stories into the mic. That would be great. Oh, my gosh. I like, I like gesturing. Can you guys hear me? Now we can. Okay, good, good stuff.
So, Jeremy, I want to kind of get, I finally want to put the Amanda issue to bed again. But Amanda, when I knew that you were coming on to our live show, Amanda was so, Amanda Anka was so excited because she had explained to me that you and Jason are kind of newish friends in the last few months. We got set up. Yeah, yeah. We've seen each other a couple of times now.
Couple times. It's very exciting. J.B., cool it. No, no, no, no. Great today, Jeremy. I feel the same. I feel the same way. that's really exciting tell me how this new found
I love new male friendships and how they start how did this start Jeremy I want to hear Jeremy's tale baby well it was it was Jamie who I think is friends with everybody Jamie Ms. Rahi who set us up a great great connector yeah she set us up we went to see some movies over at the house first so we had like a group hang
first to make sure that everything felt it wasn't awkward felt right and it was comfortable but then we got We got to go, we went to a Dodgers game, which was really, really funny, just the two of us. Always happens there. It's like an hour long ride in the car. The first one's free.
Yep, and then you sit next to me for a few hours. I've got the radio in one ear, so it's still not super pressured, you know. Yeah, it's true. And also, you don't have to fully connect with the person, so you don't have to be too. You've got something going on. Exactly. Yeah. Did you get to sit on the side of the ear that had the thing in it or not?
No. No, no, no, no. He's always, how dare you, Sean? He's on the open year. I've had both. I've had both. You've had both. Sean went to the playoff, the longest baseball game playoff history. Oh, yeah. That's really exciting. I mean, yeah, I was thinking about you a lot during, oh, last year. I went last year of the World Series, but Sean went this year. Yeah, it was great. I loved it, even though it was 18 innings. A little more enthusiasm to next delivery. I really did love it. I love going. He got thrown in the deep end, though, there with that 18- inning game.
I've learned a lot. Yeah, I don't know a lot about baseball. So, Jeremy, I mean, you must have learned a lot from, like, hanging out with an older dude. Yeah. Because I know that he's always looking to, we call him Dracula, because he's always looking to suck the young blood. He said, he's always, he's like, I need, I need. I worked on my outfit for a couple of days. I need to get me some youth.
I need to get an injection of youth. I went for, I went for a looser cut on my gene that day. I don't know if I'm good for that. Yeah, I'm not sure. Did you get anything? I did. I picked up on a couple of things. I don't really want to reveal it here,
but maybe on the next date you'll see some improvements. But did you find J.B. saying a lot of stuff like, that sounds pretty dope, dude. Yeah, that's fire. That's so fire. A couple things were suss, and Jeremy definitely had a lot of Riz that day. Wait, Jeremy, so I don't know anything about you.
Where did you grow up? I grew up in Brooklyn, New York. Oh, see, now because of the show, I think Chicago. Chicago. Like, I think that's real. Yeah. No, not that the show is real, but I thought that you had a connection to Chicago. That makes sense.
I also, I did a show before The Bear also set in Chicago. So I've been on like a Chicago set show, really my whole adult life, 18 to 45. That's what I understand. And you don't shoot the show in Chicago. Sean's always wondering what Tom Selig felt. about growing up in Hawaii. We shoot all of the bear in Chicago, yes.
Tom, you're a serve? Oh, just help me. We got to get Tom on the show. We've got to get Tom Suck and dispel that. But you've got the Detroit Tiger's hat now. Was one of your parents from Detroit? So, Jeremy, did you eat the food in Chicago? Were your parents from the...
Jeremy, Jeremy, All your time in Chicago, did anybody ever bring up Glenn Ellen? No. Not once. Well, let me ask you this. Did you eat Portillo's? Yes, I love Portillo's. Isn't it great?
Portillo's is great. Will, if you could just back the gum off the mic. Yes. The chocolate shake is huge. The chocolate shake is delicious. Yeah, it's incredible. From Bertillo's. Sean was waxing on about it before we went to Chicago.
We're like, okay, okay. And then that chocolate shake arrived, and I was like, this is a real good. It's great. It's great. By the way, Jason mentioned the cake shank. cake shake, pertilla cake shake in Ozark and he didn't remember that. Yeah. No, I don't remember that either. That's wild.
Well, he was in a blackout at the time. Do you want to address these rumors? Okay, so wait. Go ahead. All right. So, Sean, you were happy. They put the cake in a shake. Have you ever asked them to do it in an IV? Like, that would really just get it straight to the bloodstream. So, so Jeremy, we're in Brooklyn.
We're in Brooklyn. We're just learning how to read and write. We're watching cartoons. Your parents were in the field. You're when you're a kid, is that true? That's true. You read that correctly. Absolutely. And they say to you, just as you're learning how to read and write, hey, why don't you read this play?
Did it start that early? How did you get started? No, no. They weren't particularly pushy with all that. You know, when I was a kid, I had a lot of energy, and I think they just wanted to get rid of the energy. played sports, and that wasn't enough. And I did dance, which was kind of my first, like, getting on stage and performing sort of thing.
Dance. And, yeah, so I did ballet tap and jazz for a long time in New York. That's great. Can you still do it? I can look like I can do it. I mean, tap was my favorite. And I can shuffle a little bit. But, no, it's been a long time.
But when you're at a party and there's a dance floor, like, to me, that's, it looks like a quick. Pitt, like, watch out, don't get anywhere near it. Like, I've got an allergy to it. Are you thinking like, okay, all right, there's my plan for a little bit later on. Like, are you excited to dance? There was a time, like in my mid-20s, I had in L.A. and New York, like, a dance spot for almost every night of the week. Oh, my God.
No way. Yeah. Not like ballroom dancing, but, like, there was like a dance yourself clean night. There was a spot in Chinatown. There was a spot in Chinatown. There's a level of confidence to your dancing that it actually is something that you look forward to and this is a bit of a, it's a little bit of a flex
when you like you've, I don't want to put you on the spot but words in your mouth but it's not something you avoid let's put it that way. It's not something I avoid. I like to dance. God, I wish I was like to. Yeah, I'll say it. Hollywood is going to go nuts for you because you're straight
and you can dance. They're going to put you in so many. Yeah, wait until Hollywood gets a notice of you. You're going to do great. No, Matt. Get on out here. No, I met like, what's that Ryan Gosting movie? Oh, La La Land.
Yeah, La Land. Jeremy, let's say it's a Tuesday night and you know of a place in New York, you're like, all right, I'm going to go out. There's like a 70s dance thing and you've got your new buddy, J.B., and it's late for him because it's 9 o'clock and he's a little nervous about how late it is.
He wants to go to the disco. What would... I would... Could you teach him how to dance, do you think? Please. Yeah, I mean, there was a place. Sway in New York, they have the Smith's Night. And I think you could do that, right?
I love that. Can you dance to the Smith? Yeah, it's like Smith's cure, like, you know, you can figure it out, yeah. Wait, how old are you? Jason, you shut your mouth, how can you say, I go about things the wrong way. So I can just sort of just rock and sway as opposed to boogie. I'm not that much, but you've got boogie moves, yeah? I mean, I feel like the more we talk about is someone's really going to try to get me to
But you've got Boneymoot. Man, I was looking for something to put on a hat. I can dance, yes. I've got some rhythm. I can dance. I can dance.
Yeah. I'm very jealous. And I'm sure you could do it, Jason. Yes. So you're singing and dancing as a kid, which you've continued into into adulthood. And then what happened? You start doing theater?
Yeah, so I joined the, I did, I joined kind of a new school in middle school in seventh grade. and I joined the dance program naturally because I'd been doing that for a while, but I didn't find the class took dance seriously enough. Oh, boy. I didn't feel the teacher took it seriously enough.
Wow. And so I switched to the drama program. Did you have leg warmers on at the time you were in this level of disdain? Yeah, I was stretching. I had the warmers on. I did the whole thing, and I just did think they were taking it. He was a big boat in a collar. My belly was showing.
Yeah, and you're like, these fucking people. I just didn't think they took it seriously. Truly, though, I mean, it sounds ridiculous. But at the time, I was like, this doesn't feel, you know, it's like they're not taking seriously enough. And I found a drama teacher at this school, John McAnney, who took things so seriously. And some of my best friends were in this school already in this class.
And, yeah, my first time acting was like in a little black box at this school in Brooklyn, this middle school in Park Slope. Wow. And I remember, yeah, getting on it. on that stage for the first time and really feeling like a sense of, I don't know, like focus or presence or something that I hadn't been able to find, like a real ease.
Did you feel anything from the audience? Was it a comedy? Did you get a laugh or what drama? Did you feel that you'd move them? It was, no, funnily enough, it was like an exercise where we had to have two actors where a monologue was being performed, but there were two actors on stage.
And I was the actor not speaking. A dream job. And, yeah. But it was amazing to feel like if you could feel focused on the person across from you and really be listening. Like I felt attention on me, even in silence, just kind of like focusing on somebody else. And I felt like, I don't know, my mind wasn't racing. I wasn't, like, there is something, and still that's why I like acting so much. Like I find I'm so ahead of myself a lot of the time or anxious or, you know, and then when I'm on set or a performance,
performing, there's like a real like simplicity or focus or something happens that's really nice. Yeah, do you have like a little bit of ADD or something like that? For sure. Yeah, same. And then when I'm doing this, I'm working on this play right now and it's a monologue, it's 40 pages.
And I find that when I have the one thing like you're saying, to focus on, it actually calms my brain a little bit. Everything else gets kind of quiet. Yeah, and there's something really nice about that. Oh, Sean, you would describe yourself, Sean, as having a little bit of ADD? Did you say 40? pages? It's a one-man show. It's another way to put a one-man show.
He's learning a... Wow. I can't believe they're bringing puppetry of the penis back. That's so exciting. Where is the show? At Studio C-View, which is John Krasinski just did his show there last summer, I think. Which is great. Yeah. When does it go up? January 31st, it opens.
I can't make that. That's exciting. I know. Oh, no. Well, I think that's previews start January 30th. Anyway, but I know what you mean about you being able to focus it gives you something to focus on that you can put all your energy towards as opposed to feeling very like scattered
that's where my brain works I feel very scattered and same and we will be right back and now back to the show so you find this thing and you're like I'm locked in I feel locked this is something that I respond to and I like
and then you go you start auditioning for professional roles. Yeah, this teacher who was so serious. I mean, he had us doing, we did Macbeth and 12th night as 12-year-olds, back-to-back. He was just so serious as a teacher. Keep his life for the kids.
How does his 12-year-old learn Shakespeare? He would wake up, he lived near the school, and he would come to school with, like, nosebleeds when we were doing dress for her. Like, he was so, like, in it and focused, and, you know, he really... He was in something. He cared very much about it. And he would send me out on, like, he would go to Backstage, which is, like, you know, where you could do open casting calls.
And I got my first couple jobs, yeah, going on the open castles. Oh, that's great. No way, that's so rad. What was the first one? Do you remember? I did this off, off, off Broadway play called The Present. And that was kind of my first job. I think we got paid. I hope we got paid.
But yeah, that was my first job. It was like on the Upper West Side. And you were in middle school? That was in middle school. Wow. And then I think I got a commercial maybe. And then my first movie, they came to do an open casting call at the school. And a great casting director, Cindy Tolan, was casting that film.
And she told me, you know, we don't know if this movie is ever going to come together. It'll take a long time. It was a very small budget film. But she said, you know, you're good at this and you should really audition more. And so she wrote me a really great letter to take around to agents and stuff. So I ended up getting an agent.
That's great. Wow. Yeah, thank you, Cindy Tolan. Now, was singing ever a part of this? I forgot. No. It was not. No, no.
Just dance, yeah. So then musical theater was never really a draw or a temptation. But how about now? Now that you've taught yourself how to sing. I mean, your performance is so mind-blowing in the Springsteen thing. I don't want to embarrass you. We don't have to talk about it because I'm sure you're tired of talking about it.
But it's just effing incredible. And the fact that you learn how to sing in someone else's voice on top of that and learned how to play guitar, I think, too. You get to learn how to play guitar for this role. To take on that. At least look like I could handle it. Yeah. Wow.
Incredible. Huge, huge nards. taken that on and doing such a great job. Jason was going on and on about how, I'm so sorry, I haven't seen it yet, but it's on my list, I swear. But Jason was just raving about your performance and as everybody else.
He's incredible. I can't wait to see it. So now that you've got the singing and the dancing, and I don't know if you need the guitar part for a musical theater, but like, do you think about doing like a musical on Broadway or something? Like a la la la la. I don't know. I mean, it's never been, I mean, I have no
issue and I've like enjoyed musical theater but it's like seeing it, but it's never been, like in high school, I went to a performing arts school and I would do theater, but it was usually kind of straight plays and stuff. And, yeah, I don't know. I've never had that draw to be in it.
I've been a fan of it. But you wouldn't run if somebody brought you something. Let's say like the new Hamilton kind of thing. Or like as Sean would mention for 50 times, La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La La. Jesus. Guys, why you marry that movie? La La Land 2, I would definitely be interested in doing.
How about the Christmas sequel, Fala La Land? Fala Land. J.B, that's really good. Thanks, guys. That is nice. Wait, so are you, do you play an instrument now? Like, do you play anything piano or anything else? No, I mean, I never really learned how to play anything.
And I remember, you know, I had about six months to learn guitar, which, you know, isn't enough time, really, to learn how to play the guitar. But I got together with a really great teacher and we just learned the couple songs that I needed to learn, but it makes it very hard for me to learn or to play other things now because I didn't learn in a traditional way. So even if I try to learn something else, I kind of end up playing Mansion on a Hill or something.
Like it doesn't translate it. You still have fallaces on the tips of your fingers? Yeah, they're still a little rough. Really? Because it hurts, right? And I still pick up, I mean, you know, Bruce Springsteen, he was so involved in kind of the process of making the movie
and really lovely and supportive all the way through but yeah you seem to really love it yeah yeah he's seen it a lot but he bought me a 1955 Gibson J200 which is the same model
and almost year he he recorded it on 1954 but after our first meeting he sent me this guitar which is very beautiful guitar and so I do pick it up every once in a while just because I feel guilty letting it sit and collect dust. Is it there in the office and you're in your
you know what? As I said, my house is falling apart when that rain was happening. I was nervous that there would be some moisture in here. So it's actually under my bed at this moment and where it's really safe. That's smart. You know, I bought a Christmas tree here yesterday in New York and I dragged it back to my place here we decorated yesterday. Did somebody film it?
And I thought, you know, yeah, obviously I film everything. And I thought about I thought about if I ever wanted to I'd have a Christmas tree stand down on Spring Street, you know, just this season and I'd call spruce of Spring Street. You know what I mean? Nice.
Bravo. That was worth it. That was worth it. Wait, we'll tighten it up. So, Jeremy, so what was the first thing then after all that theater experience that got you out to the West Coast? I got a job. I was very lucky right out of high school.
I got a job on a TV show called Shameless. Oh, yes, of course. Of course you're on that. Yeah, fantastic. You were on for like a decade. Am I right about that? More. I was, man, I was 18 when we did the pilot,
and I was 30 when we finished. Wow. What takes you through a lot. And that was the first gig, or the first big gig? I did, yeah. I did some film and like every law and order and stuff like that when I was in New York.
But yeah, Shameless brought me to Los Angeles. and kept me in Los Angeles. Yeah, that's so cool. That's incredible. 18 to 30. Yeah, it just doesn't happen. Right. So you're inside that cocoon, that comfortable cocoon of a series
through your whole launch, right? And you've got great notices through that and you're meeting everybody and you're getting other opportunities during the hiatuses in between each season a little bit? Yeah, I try to do something, you know. Yeah, I try to do something each hiatus we shot about five months and yeah if I was lucky I'd get a movie or or I did another like an
Amazon sort of series one time but but yeah I mean I didn't have to I mean I was so happy and felt so lucky to have that kind of like I don't know that consistency and kind of continuity in my life especially in my 20s especially as an actor to kind of just have have some place you knew where you were going to be for four months every year five months every year. Did you have time to also have a life? I mean, that takes you all the way through your 20s. Like, that's a time when you really want to have fun.
Did you find time to do all that stuff too? Yeah, definitely found time for all that stuff. Yeah, I mean, I bounced around. Like, we shot the show here, and I got a place back home in New York when I was like 22, and so I'd kind of, like, split my time between L.A. and New York. And then, yeah, I mean, by the time we finished the show, I had, you know, You know, I had my two daughters. A lot of life happened.
Wow, you have two kids? Yes, he and Dolly. Yeah, yeah, two daughters, yeah. Wow. How old are that? Dolly turns five on Friday, and Esi turned seven in October. I mean, you still look like you're 30, which is crazy. I know. Well, how old were, I mean, I was 27.
Yeah, when Ezzie was born. Yeah. Wow. Yeah. In that time, did you ever cross-over? I think he wrote on your show, Mike O'Malley. Didn't he right now? Oh, my gosh, of course.
Yeah. He's a good friend of all of ours. Yeah. Mike was a writer on Shameless? He was on Glee at the same time, too, which was like such a huge show. And I was like, oh, wow, you're such a big actor and you're writing on our show.
Mike's had a really cool career. Like, really cool career. Right? Mike's had a really cool career so far. Yeah, I love that guy. Has he done acting, stand up, writing, producing. He's done it all. He's such a talented guy, such a talented writer.
And we all, I mean, he's such a great old, old friend of mine. He's not that old, Will. No. All right. He's just the best. We love you, Mike. He's a sweetheart. He is a sweetheart.
So that takes you through to your third. All of a sudden, so now you're 30, and it's weird coming off a show when you've been on it for a long time, right? That's a weird. Yeah, did you think, like, okay, it's all going to be downhill from here? 100%.
I felt totally, I mean, you know, I... Leave the cocoon. Yeah, I remember, I mean, I really did. We did ADR for the last, for whatever, the last episode of the 11th season of Shameless. I was at Warner Brothers. So, Tracy, that's where you re-recorded some dialogue if it didn't, if it wasn't recorded well on the day.
It's sort of a finishing process. There you go. There you go. Yeah, it means kind of the end. It's your last connection often with the thing. And I finished that and I was driving home from Warner Brothers and had a full, like, panic. I had to pull over, my arms went, I was so...
Wow, really? Wow. Yeah, I mean, it had just been such a comfort. And, you know, I was with those actors for 11 years, and, I mean, they're like my family, brothers and sisters. Like, I got so close with everybody, and I felt like I was saying goodbye to not only kind of, like, my work environment and that sort of, like, comfort and security, but also saying goodbye to these people
who had been so solid for me for so long. And yeah, I just didn't know what was next. And I had a very hard time. How did you, what was the thing that was most helpful that got you to, because I know that panic well. Yeah. What do you, did you lean on a friend? Did you go into therapy?
I mean, I'm just citing all the things that I get, friends, therapy. I partied. I like, you know, just everything. Yeah. What? I certainly, yeah, was in therapy. and was talking about her a lot. But I was also very lucky, like, so, I mean, you know,
there's so much luck involved in all of this thing. But, you know, I spoke to Chris Storer, who created The Bear. He produced this movie I did, The Rental, like, after season nine of Shameless. And Chris, I didn't see him on set a lot. He was kind of back and forth, but he comes up to me on kind of the last day. and Chris goes Hey what do you think you're going to be doing in three years And I don't really know
Like you know I think I got a couple more years of shameless And he goes all right buddy I'm going to call you in three years And he walked away And I was like what a fucking jerk Like what a Hollywood jerk Like there's no way I'm ever going to hear from that guy Ever again
And he called me Just as we were wrapping up season 11 And said I have to show the bear You know, I'd really like you to do it But I was hesitant at first Because it was, you know, I love Chicago But based in Chicago again And there was some kind of like family dynamics
That seemed like similar upon first read to me And so I just wasn't sure I'd do it yet But I just kept reading the script for the bear and the pilot And it was so great And I got to the point where I was just like You know, it's not my business to pass I have no right to pass on something this this good.
So even though I was anxious about the future and all this stuff, I was shooting the pilot for the bear probably two months after that panic attack. I knew I was going somewhere. So I was able to kind of throw myself into something else. Yet it was still just a pilot, right?
So you had to sweat. Totally. The delivery of that, the network reading it or sorry, watching it and giving it a pickup, right? FX, I believe still is one of the, I don't think it's like
this is kind of inside baseballer, but it's like you know, I think a lot of shows will go straight to series these days with streaming but FX continues to sort of, they shoot a pilot everybody watches it, they see what it looks like, they take a look at, you know,
what you want to do with the first season. Well, they make pretty good shows over there, so they're they do. No, no, wonderful. We have a question about staying in Chicago, so those 11 seasons you did of Shameless and then the bear, Do you find a new place to stay every time you go, or do you have a hub that you stay at? What a great question, Sean?
That's great. Thank you. What part of Shikonk? Who's your broker? So we shot most of shameless in L.A. But we'd go for like a week at a time. Oh, I got it. Okay, got it.
So we'd stay in a hotel. I thought you shot the whole thing there. No, no, no. Yeah, no. First week in showbiz. We do. We're catching. We're catching.
We do shoot all of the bear in Chicago, and we stay all in the same place, and it's great, because all of us are, like, on the same floor, and we all cook together and eat together. Oh, that's great. Is breakfast included? Yeah, exactly, yeah. Right, right.
Okay, wow. But, yeah. So Apollo 13, the movie, they didn't film that in space, then, no? A portion of it. Okay, so you get the bear. So now you start doing the bear. So you come out of this, by the way, Sean, I was going to ask you,
you also had that thing with like Will and Grace, how long was that on the air? Yeah, how long? Total 11 seasons, but broken up to 8 and 3. So did you feel when that was over? Yeah. Well, you know, I try to be self-aware. I'm sure these guys did too during Rest Development
that you know when something's working and you have a gig and you have job security and somewhere to go every day and hopefully every year with each season that you start trying to think ahead. Like, okay, I'm self-aware enough to know that this is working now, I have to use this to get another gig.
I have to make sure I can parlay this into another gig. And as hard as you try, you just can't, like Jason always says, you can't control it. You can't control, you know, where your career goes. You can try, but it's like, you know, just kind of do your part. You do have to let go. Yeah.
We never, well, certainly unarrested, we never had. How long was arrested? The first incarnation was three years. Oh, right, but then you guys came back. We never had job security, even when, after we went. won the Emmy, we were on the verge of being canceled the next week. That's so crazy. It's such a
great show. That's unbelievable. Every time we go past the guard shack at studio, we'd wonder if there'd still be a drive on for us. But you guys knew how good it was. You guys could all feel how good it was, right? I mean, it's like a boring question. But it was like, but we were all a bunch of weirdos on that show. We're like, well,
is this going to translate? Are other people going to think this is funny? Yes, we never knew. I never had, I never had that job security. I never had like a long term job in that way. Right. And yet you work more than literally anybody, I know. I don't know if that's true, but it's weird.
You're doing okay, Will. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. So you get that, so now you come off that and then all of a sudden you find yourself you're shooting the pilot and then the show gets picked up and could you have predicted that the bear would make, would resonate with fans and critics and everybody as much as it did when you were doing it?
even more so than shameless. Yeah. Yeah, no, I mean, you know, I think all of you guys know that the feeling of kind of making something and knowing that it feels exciting and fresh and that you love all the other actors and everybody's doing such great work. But then, you know, that almost doesn't matter, you know, you put something out and will it connect or will anybody watch? It's just a whole other thing. So I think we all knew how exciting it was to make and we all hope. hoped we could do more. But I think my greatest hope for the show when we were shooting the first season
was like maybe we can find kind of like a niche sort of like market where like people in service really dig this show or like, you know, like it's like respected by, I think that was the goal is like will kitchens like this show, will back of house like this show, does this seem real? So the fact that it connected with as many people as it did and was watched as much.
as it has been was definitely a surprise yeah and you're on year what you're on year four of the bear we will start shooting five next year wow yeah yeah how many episodes of season it changes it's sometimes it's eight sometimes it's 10 but it's always right around there yeah that's great and now you're a great big movie star on top of it all too like how you's gonna stuff it all in bud oh man what I feel like I want to take a take a nap I don't know
I'm very like I'm excited to go do the you know the next season of the show and then I'm like I mean it's been so lovely what the show has given me but I'm definitely I definitely want to like hang out at home and take the kids to school and stuff yeah because it does seem like those things
there are people that are uniquely suited to like constantly be in a public position and sort of do that whole thing. Away from home and all that stuff. Yeah, it's hard. Yeah, that really like to be at home, that are sort of private, that are sort of shy,
that it's sort of antithetical to the whole public job, right? And you do seem to be someone that enjoys, like me, I think all three of us, who kind of enjoy being kind of nesters. Yeah, trying to find a bit of a routine or a little bit of, like, I don't know. rhythm you know i i get very thrown and when you go out you feel like you got to like kind of throw the switch a little bit and kind of okay now we got to kind of do this a bit but it kind of
becomes a part of you is that is it become a comfortable part of you which part like just like flying around and yeah and doing the thing and and and and promoting stuff and everybody's like looking at you and going like being a public figure there's jeremy you know i mean yeah i don't know i mean i don't think that i'll ever feel for me like a comfortable thing but i think you can get better at sort of like hiding your anxiety perhaps yeah for sure you know what you know what's funny jeremy like this weekend actually at one point i was on somewhere on social media and a photo came up and if you have in our friend uh jamie who we just mentioned yeah uh and and it and it was like seen with unidentified and i was like there we go you're there with jamie who you work with yes
and then and then people sort of glob you know sort of lobbing comments and saying like who's this person Who's the person? Who's the person? And you're just like, hey, man, the guy's out where he's working or he's doing this and he's in the city. Like, it's just, and that part is bizarre, right? It's just, it never gets really normal. Are you able to see that as kind of fun and funny? Yeah, I mean, you know, I love Jamie and I've known her for so long.
So, like, that kind of thing is funny. And that's what I get for, you know, whatever, staying at the Bowery. But I just, but no, that stuff is, yeah, it's like, it's like, it's, strange you certainly don't get used to it like i i have this farmer's market i i love to go to and i've gone to for you know six seven years that's very close to my house and i go every sunday and and i feel like that thing that was mine or me and my daughters or like whatever that very like private kind of like nice routine has kind of been yeah like spoiled by that sort of uh the attention so so yeah when those things happen i mean i understand it comes with you know i'm i'm very lucky to
be working in this career that I've wanted to be in for so long and have these opportunities and this is something that comes with it. But yeah, none of it is normal, you know, none of it feels normal. Do you talk to your kids about it? Like, do you explain, try to explain it to them? Are they old enough yet? Yeah, I mean, I just try to explain it as like people get excited, you know, they know I'm on television and they'll see like posters and things and, you know, I explain that people get excited about kind of thinking they understand a version of your dad,
but it's not really your dad. And I'm, you know, you know me and these people don't really know me, but they get excited because they see this version of me. But Ezzie, my oldest spots people quicker than I do. She's got like a real like hawk eye
for people. When someone pretends to be going through their emails. Put it up their phone or doing a double take. be like, we better keep moving. That's great. And she's seven? So it's nice that she's sharp. Yeah, I'm glad that she's, you know.
I was with somebody once, and somebody was taking like a sneaky pick of them, and then came up and said, can I get a pick? And they said, you already got it. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Respect, you know, respect. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
J.B., what have you, have you ever, what do you say to your girls? your girls are older now but did you say back in the day have that convo with them i made a mistake early on of um we know but i want to know about this um i remember once we were driving past a poster and uh and and one of my daughters said oh we were driving to school and she's like oh i can't wait to tell my friends that you know you're on a poster and i my instinct was i said no no no you can't you can't do don't ever say and i kind of because i didn't want her to be you know bragging or like Right, right, right. I try, I overcompensated and kind of made it.
Right, it landed in a way that was like panicked about. Right, that you should hide the fact of what your dad does. Like they almost thought that what I did was a bad thing. Right, right. And so I kind of had to undo that. But, you know, what do I, I never had kids before his first for me. I mean, how old were, when was, yeah, how did you guys handle that kind of stuff, you and Amanda?
It's, you know, you just, you try to keep an eye on, like, when's the first possible moment they can understand the smart version of this conversation. Right. You know, and try to have it then as opposed to the dumb version of the conversations, which is what I had. And it's just sort of just like, you know, a big dull, you know, dumb, blunt instrument, you know, saying, no, this is bad. Don't talk about it.
This is, you know, over here is good. And it just was kind of stupid. So I just kind of kicked the can down the road for a bit, I guess. Jeremy, what's your dream role? Great, great, great. I want to hear this. Yeah, I know this is great. One more thing on Chicago.
So what was the commute like from the place you guys were staying? Well, Sean, I will. I mean, do you go back a lot? Like, do you have a restaurant I should be going to that I don't know about? Like, what's going on? Yeah, I love that. Jeremy, okay, go ahead. I love the R.L. restaurant, the Ralph Lauren Polo restaurant.
Of course. It's the best. Come on, really? We can all walk. It's the best. For lunch, we're there. Chris Dor, the creator of the creator of the restaurant. the Bears there every, every day.
And it's attached to the Ralph Lauren store. So you just go shopping. I believe it's Ralph Lauren. You know what? The one in Paris is very good too. It's actually, really, really good. But Jared, like, is there, because you have so much going on and you have to balance, you know, like you said, be nice to take my kids to school or whatever, is there something that's coming up or something that you've always wanted to do where you're just like, God, I really need to do that, I really want to do that, I have to get this.
But I can't do it because of kids. Or I have to figure it out. I don't know. I mean, I don't think of, you know, I kind of take things as they come. Like you are like, I have to play Bruce Springsteen. It was more like a collaborative, hey, what do you think about this? Yeah, I mean, that came, yeah, Bruce came to me and the script came to me through Scott Cooper, who's a director I've, like, admired for really long time.
Great filmmaking. And I think that's how I always move is sort of who are the directors, who are the writer. who are the producers, like, who are the actors I want to work with? So, like, the genre or the world, while those can be, like, very exciting things are almost secondary to, you know, I really want to work with Paulo Sorrentino, or I really, like, every actor wants to just do, like,
a line in a Paul Thomas Anderson movie, you know, that's always kind of what I'm looking for. There's no sort of, like, archetype or world that I'm necessarily, like, I need to do this. Got it, got it, got it. Sean, what about you, something fun? What would you like to do right now? I'm serious that somebody said,
you can pick a genre right now, what would you do? I want to play, I told you, I want to play a complete fucking maniacal serial killer. Or someone who's just, you would never, ever expect me to play. Like, I want to play the super nice guy who is, you know, affable and kind of just, like, funny or whatever. And then he fucking rips people's necks apart when nobody's around. So that's his mode as he rips people's neck apart? That's right. I wrote it down.
You want me to send it to you? Okay. Again. What kind of weapon would you, would your guy use, Sean? Just my hands. Wow. I've had a cake knife. How about think about it for a second?
Jesus, let me get the question. Just trying to cover up the motivation, let him finish the, just my hands. But no, you know, kind of like, you know like, you know like, you're like, you're like, who is this guy? Like, he can't. No, he wasn't, I mean, he worked all the time before that, but that was what made him famous. You're like, wow, that's such a cool, crazy...
Sean, do we need to go look into your garage? Is this something? Do we need to be searching? Everything's fine, everything's fine. Willie, what about you? Yeah. What's that? What about it, like a drink?
You could rub the genie bottle. Next, next role, next part. It's a... Or it could be a genre. It's a newborn. The newborn. You'd like to be, you'd like to do some action work. Takeover, yeah, in the first scene, Maddie and I battle it out.
Sure. And then I, and with the silencer, I take him out. And you take his wallet and his identification. And I take his identification. And right before he does, Damon looks at me and goes, you're the best. And then I take over. Wow. But you haven't thought about it.
Well, I want him to compliment me before, you know what I mean? His last words. Now, do you, but in all honesty, if somebody came to you with like a big-ass action, film right now, would you not think about the fact that the stunt work could be very challenging? I feel like that stuff's exciting to me.
I mean, that all feels like that all feels like that. He's a young guy. He's not scared of that, Jason. No, what about you? Will, do you think you'd tell you, would you say yes to some stunt work? You'd blow out your fucking hammy coming out of your fucking dressing room. Coming out of your dressing room.
Oh! I'm out! I'm out! I'm out! I'm out! says you, JB would show up for his first stuff and they'd be like, you can't do this in slippers. But I think that, yeah, I would actually think more
about the time that would take to be a way to do something like that and the first one would freak me out more than anything, to be honest. That's looking like six months, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I know, it is such a big factor in deciding, isn't it? Like, where am I going to be and for how long and what, yeah.
Yeah, and we all have, you know, we have kids and you have lives and stuff, and especially at our age, Jeremy, you're lucky that you're sort of young. You have all these kind of... But for me, I'm like, oh, God, I'm so tired. Yeah. You have a young one.
I do. I do. I have a five-year-old. I have a five-year-old and a 15-year-old and a 17-year-old. So these are like... You are tired. Yeah, I am tired. And these are...
Although my five-year-old slept through the night last night, which he hasn't been doing for a while, but he did last night, which was a big... Even though I look crazy exhausted right now. Is he sleep in bed with you? No, no. because that's a slippery slope but it is a slippery
you know sometimes I'll go down and sort of get in and sort of calm him down and stuff like that if he wakes up in the night but yeah he's not a great sleeper but anyway
we're getting you know hey listen it's cool I'm 55 hey um yeah can you can you oh is it Jare now
yeah yeah sure why not I don't have the time do people call you Jared are you called Jare by your friends Jare yeah Jair bears, yeah. How about Jodog?
Yeah. Jodog is, yeah, a lot. No, truly? Yeah. Yeah. J. J.O. was in like middle school, high school. Jawbone.
On the bear set, jaw dog is around. This, I'm being genuine. I love it. Jaw dog. Yes, of course. Well, my initials, yeah, or J.W. Yeah, I got it. We can do the math.
Okay. So listen, but when, Because I know what you mean. Sean, your hair is distracting. I'm getting it. Yeah, what time's the gig later on? You just cover all flock of seagulls and nothing else, right? No, I have a figure skating gig next little bit.
But, Jerr, do you have... Because I'm talking about the anxiety thing and stuff like that. Do you, can you, when you're not working and you have family, can you shut it off and not think about agents and lawyers? and deals and scripts and all that stuff, can you completely separate, or is it always kind of there? I think, yeah, I mean, that's, you know,
when I'm around, yeah, my kids, you're forced to just, you have to be completely present. It's like, so I guess that's, yeah, the second time I found kind of real peace or focus is, yeah, and having kids, everything just kind of like narrowed, and you're like, oh, this is it. This is, you know, this is where my attention is. This is where I want to be.
This is, you know. Right. And so, yeah, I'm able to do that when I'm home. Yeah, for sure. And when it's not kids, when it's not, what else are you, like, what is just you, what do you do to completely decompress? No work, no kids, something stupid, something settling. is there, what would we be surprised to learn
is your weird-ass hobby or your shitty TV show that you watch? I mean, I watch... Well, okay, so I'm obsessed with, like, reality, real estate shows. And I'm, like, always on my realtor at. I don't buy anything, but I like to fantasize about, like, buying stuff all the time.
That's why those shows are so popular. We do, too, the three of us do. I send listings to friends and they're like, just buy it then. Like, what do you want for me? And I'm like, no, I don't know, I don't know. Wait, so like those weird realtors? Million dollar listing.
Yeah, selling sunset or owning Manhattan just started up again. I'm very excited. My guy, Ryan Sirhan. Yeah, Brian Surhant is like incredible. Came from nothing and built an empire. I'm very impressed by that man. Easy.
No, but I mean, it's cool. Yeah, but that's my. like I, you know, I just like look at stuff. If I'm visiting, like, I don't know, I'm like traveling for work or even like I like doing road trips. I don't know if I'm in a small town I think is really sweet. Instantly I'm kind of on like Zillow or the realtor app. And I'm like, what if I got another place here?
What if I just like, you know, would come here all the time? What is it? I do the same thing. Wherever I go, I'm immediately thinking about getting a place there. Is it because that's how I could feel like at home there? Yeah, maybe. Yeah, maybe it's a way to try to, like, get some control over, I feel like a lot of it comes back to control for me. Exactly. I want to be a local immediately.
What's the weirdest place that you ever, like, seriously concerned? Like, maybe I will get a place here. Was there ever one of those? Bisbee, Arizona. Wow. Really? I was really considering. Yeah, I did a road trip.
I've driven cross-country like four or five times, and I did one from L.A. to New York in December. This was like, I don't know, 10 years ago. And the first stop was Bisbee, Arizona, which is like a very small town. It looks kind of like Laurel Canyon. Like the buildings are very pastel colors, and it's kind of hilly. But it's in the middle of no. It's like desert, desert, desert, very small town, but very sweet. And I spent the night there and a bed and breakfast.
Got up the next day, was like walking around, talking to locals. And everybody I spoke to, like nobody was from Bisby. Everybody was just passing through. and then they opened a sandwich shop or they opened a clothing store and it started to feel a little like twilight episode-y where I was like, oh, maybe this is one of those towns
you stop in and you just, you can't get out of and I did get out, but then for about six months I was considering getting like a little house in Bisbee Arizona. What about these drives across country? Did you, did you ever have a big run in with a cop? Do you like to speed?
I didn't, I'm really responsible on the road. You are? So you do the speed limit across the country? I go 10 above the speed limit. Okay. Yeah, it's what you set the cruise control. They won't have you. I just keep going at 10, yeah.
But I did get a flat in St. George when I was driving cross-country a couple years ago. In the middle of the night, there was no one around. I didn't have cell service, and that was spooky. That's the worst. And then I finally got a cop stopped, and I got a spare. and I was going to spend the night in Vegas I was on my way back to LA but there was like a fight night
and everything was booked everything I'm talking like holiday ins were booked all the nice hotels were booked eventually I got a hotel room was like the only hotel room left in Las Vegas but it was like $2,000 for the night it had a bowling out
it was like so absurd so I spent $2,000 to like lie down at 2 a.m and then pretty much get up at 6 a.m. to go get a real tire put on the car. Right, because you just had a little pizza cutter back to L.A. I just needed to sleep. You just slept in your car. I should have.
I should have. That's what I'm here for. Oh, should. Yeah. Yeah. Another thing for you, the list for your time machine. I know what you mean about that real, like anytime Scotty and I go anywhere, we immediately go, I always ask them like, could you live here? Could you live here? Could you live there? And it's always a small point. Those are
many like Dunkin franchises and stuff like that. Right? No, but like, it's always the same thing where I think I would go, I think the idea of living smaller in a quaint town like Bisbee or whatever is great. But then the reality is, I don't know, this New York or L.A. or Miami or Chicago, the city really keeps you kind of going and alive. Yeah, I'd feel too isolated, I think. Yeah, a little bit.
I need some big town, too. Well, you're, for two things are, A, Sean, that is that, Sean does do that because I know for a fact, Sean will go even further. He won't even just look at online. He'll go and look at property with a local realtor. For sure, 100%. He does it all the time. Oh, whoa.
Yes. Commitment. But you bought and you'll pull the trigger. No, God, no. No, no, no, no. He's wasting so many realtors' time. It's not even funny. He's like, persona and on a real whale.
Yeah. But the other thing is I've noticed, sorry, go ahead, Sean. No, I just skip with that idea, Jeremy, the idea, like, do you come from a small town, and you prefer cities now? No, I grew up in Brooklyn. You're at the start of the show, right? I know, but Brooklyn isn't like a, like, you know, Brooklyn's city like, so do you prefer the opposite of that as you get older
because you didn't grow up that way? Maybe, I mean, yeah, I definitely like the idea of maybe one day having a place that's more slow moving and I have a, you know, a smaller place in L.A. Or if I'm back in New York, I have an apartment in the city, go upstate or Long Island or something like that. You ever see yourself getting
like a bunch of land and being like one of those guys with a bunch of like ranch, ranch tools and Kevin Costas. Again, like the fantasy of it. Yeah, I think. A bunch of props. What is it Jason's stuff
that the prop department hands you? Yeah. You know, one of those cap guns. You're holding it upside down, Mr. Bateman. I'd be so useless. I think for a week it could be fun. Yeah, yeah. I hear you.
fantasy of it, but very quickly I'd realize there's no... I could see you upstate. I could see you upstate or on Long Island. Yeah, I have some friends that are up there and it's, and you know, I think it's sweet and then and then, yeah, Long Island I think is really nice and I rented a place last
summer there that I really loved and and, and yeah, and all my people, my folks are still in Brooklyn, my sisters in Brooklyn. Oh, yeah, that's great. So I like going back there and being close. Well, personally I'd like you stay here in Los Angeles. Did you see each other? It is nice.
What was the last movie? What was the last movie night? It's been a while. I mean, I'm still watching them. Yeah. But the door is still unlocked, a jar even, waiting for you people to come back. Fucking less creepy would be great.
Just a little less creepy would be nice. That's the name of my autobiography. The door's a jar. The door is a jar. Gross. That's disgusting. God, it's so gross. Jimmy Allen, you are the man, man, man.
I appreciate you. I appreciate you. It's just incredible. It's so well-deserved. You've worked hard for it, and you've been just consistently great all the way along. So we're big, big fans. I speak for Sean. Jason has his own take on it, which is a little more lascivious.
No, I'm not there yet. Okay. I'm working on him. I'm trying to play hard to get. Love you, Jeremy, get over here again. This is a pleasure. Thank you, thank you, thank you. Nice to be tuned.
Thanks for doing this, buddy. Be good, you guys. You're the best. See you, see you, see you. Will, did you get that full plate of food done? I know. First of all, he said, you're the best, and he was looking at me. Do you see that?
No, he was looking at my box. He was looking at me. You got a full plate of food delivered to you at the beginning of interview. Did you get it all done? What is it? It was like a chicken salad or something. Like a chicken salad. Oh, it was chicken salad.
Yeah. And who was that? It would seem like somebody was on their hands and knees down there at the door opening. She didn't want to interrupt. She didn't want to interrupt. It was Carolyn? That was Carolyn on her hands and knees?
She wasn't on her hands and knees. She bent down to put it at the door because she didn't want to interrupt. She was being very respectful. She should have come in. I love her. I know. I love her.
Don't you mess that up, Will. Oh, my God. Jesus. If it starts to get wobbly, you just hand it over and let us fix it, and then we'll give it back. Yeah. That's how relationships work, right? Yeah, sure.
That's exactly how it works. You're handed over? Oh my God, I'm out of milk. Sean, is this the same Snickerdoodle? Yeah, he just killed it. It was really big. The last bite. Good boy. No, there's some more left him.
Well, I'm really fond of... Oh, he's just the greatest. He's such a nice guy. I've only met him a couple of times. He's so nice. He's a good, normal person. He's really great. It would have been great up there on that stage. Are we going to reschedule that?
Are we going to do the bowl, maybe, like, in the spring or something like that, maybe? Let's make a commitment that we're going to do something. Spring, summer, something like that. Let's for sure do it when it's not rainy season. We can't do it in the summer because they do the Philharmonic there in the summer. Every night? Most of it's programmed.
Why can't you do it over the summer? What about the beginning? L.A. Phil's in there through the summer. Are you like one night? Like September or like October before the rain starts. No, I don't argue with me. I'm happy to do it at any point. I think it's all about the guess.
When can we get guests in there? You know, we've got to get some big shot guests because we're not cutting it, okay? People aren't coming out to see us blather on sitting on a couch. They want to see the stars. Wait, how did you and Jeremy meet again? A grinder. Oh, wow.
Wow. He's so candid about it. J.B., I didn't know this. Sean didn't want to say it because he's embarrassed because the same guy created the bear. Sean is about to do, they're doing a spin-off. He's doing the Cub. It's a different show.
It's a different... It's a different... It's on YouTube or it's on porn tube or whatever. But whatever, it doesn't matter. Hey, listen, it sounds fun. By the way, when I saw the title of the bear, I was like, I'm in, click. Oh, it's about a restaurant.
Mim, man, yeah, click on. People talking about food. Wait, is Grindr, is Grindr the hetero one or the gay one? Nice try. Which one? Say it, listen, oh, yeah. Hey, I'm confused. I don't believe a word.
Wait, what are you doing? I'm so confused. Hand to God on my kid's life. I don't, which is which is which? Which is what? What are you asking? Is it Tinder? One of them's the gay one.
Yeah, Grindr's the gay one. You're acting so nervous. You're acting so nervous. I just want to make sure they get that on. And he's like, and delete account. We're still recording. Wait, you know, when Jeremy was playing Bruce Springsteen. Oh boy, here we go.
Jesus. There is a song that I wonder because I haven't seen it yet. I haven't seen the show yet. And I wonder. if he sang the song in the movie called Johnny Bye-bye. Do you know that song that... At least commit to it? No, I was just like...
Go right. Bye. Bye, bye, bye, that's good. Bye. Smartless. Smart. Yes. Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbecue. Co., Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.